whoa aah welcome to the first annual  gridiron heights Thanksgiving dinner the  seat next to me is for the most  important person in my life  it's for Dad come on pop a squat and  Tony Romo flop you can sit at the  kickers table we hate ourselves too of  course Ronny camera here it's Black  Friday business is booming  sweet belt buckle hat vine thanks that's  a really cool tent cam  it's my jacket in my household we have a  thrice daily tradition where we say what  we're thankful for  I'm thankful for family friends it's  wonderful food that Vaughn tez can have  because he's a really nice person with a  heart of gold I'm thankful for my stupid  brother knew you were gonna say that  Rockhouse say words ahem despite the  deep competitive nature in each of us  behind our facemasks we are the same we  are coworkers we are friends and gosh  darn it we are family and for that I am  thankful  okay now groggy dead bird leg